[Music]
helicopter
machine gun kelly and travis barker's
surprise concert had some vips in the
front row
blonde gorgeous on saturday megan fox
and kourtney kardashian attended their
boyfriend's rooftop jam
in venice beach hey brookside venice
beach one hour
i love you guys i'm up to no good today
courtney even brought along good friend
addison ray who shared this killer view
to her instagram
in this pic the women were all smiles as
they listened to the guys rock out
and it's not the first time the couples
have doubled up in march the foursome
enjoyed a night out at ufc
260. a source told et at the time quote
they have a great time when they hang
out as couples and it's very natural
easy and fun i don't know if people
understand what a good actor he is he's
so charismatic and he's so naturally
gifted
he's also a brilliant creative genius as
a musician
so then for him to show up on set and
just be so much better than you at what
you do for a living
the concert also follows courtney
sharing these pda pics to her instagram
with her and travis locking lips in a
recording studio
travis commented on the post quote my
baby
barker and kelly recently collaborated
on mgk's album
tickets to my downfall
the album went on to reach number one on
the billboard charts
so how would you describe your
relationship today
i feel like we're great friends
and co-parents yeah i mean we're family
you know
i think we always will be in this
preview clip from part two of keeping up
with the kardashians reunion which airs
sunday
the family has some fun with scott's
rumored jealousy about courtney's love
life
it seems like you get really upset when
courtney is linked to other guys
me yeah no no no no
um
he said i just want to kill them you
just want to kill them okay
okay is he the last guy let's all be
honest nobody was happy with the last
one
really yeah scott and everyone else
i was still there to try to help her
through